make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on with Doomsday Clock I
want to talk about I'll talk about
Doomsday Clock and in reality I don't
even know if anybody cares about this
anymore because the truth of Doomsday
Clock is you're talking about a story
that's taken three years essentially to
finish and at the time that it was
introduced try for those of you guys who
aren't really reading DC at the moaner
who have never read DC Comics at the
time that Doomsday Clock
was introduced that is to say like they
were gonna go forward with the Doomsday
Clock story the biggest interest people
had was dr. Manhattan right you have
this guy with an insane amount of power
and everybody wanted to know how he
stacked up right that was the big
question people had how does dr.
Manhattan stack up against some of the
big heavy hitters in DC Comics at the
end of the day that's what we want to
know right I mean the story's cool and
everything but like we want to know like
what would happen if like the spectre
fought dr. Manhattan you know what would
happen if these two characters fought
you know it's like dr. fate met dr.
Manhattan you know like how would that
whole thing go down that's what we want
to see that's the conflict we want to
see like if DC started releasing a
series of one shots you know like dr.
Manhattan versus dr. fate
dr. Manhattan versus like Superman one
million dr. Manhattan versus Superboy
pod do those things would sell like
gangbusters they would sell us so bad I
could make those videos on my youtube
channel and they would explode right a
million views each I mean people want to
see that like people want to see that
kind of stuff because dr. Manhattan you
know much like Galactus little axis
guardian it's like an ago is this being
with just like an insurmountable amount
of power and you guys were remember you
know a lot of the theories that were
going around at the time right this idea
that like dr. Manhattan is the reason
why the new 52 exists right you know
that you had Barry Allen who went back
in time to save his mom's life and ended
up treating the flashpoint universe as a
result and so we had to basically go
back in time and let her die and when he
did that dr. Mann hadn't stepped in and
changed things we saw like all these
little little you know or at least had
all these little theories on everything
that dr. Manhattan's done over the
course of his time in the DC Universe to
mess things up a lot of the Doomsday
Clock story is rectified that right so
the reason why the Justice Society of
America doesn't exist is because at the
moment when Allen Scott was supposed to
discover the Green Lantern and then
become a superhero that the Green
Lantern was moved slightly out of his
reach and so the result was that he
ended up being hit by the train instead
of
give me the green lantern itself and the
result was that there was no Alan Scott
Green Lantern meaning there was no
formation of the Justice Society of
America hence the reason it doesn't
exist it was cool you know to see those
little little tidbits thrown in those
little tidbits introduced but the
reality of this is that with regards to
how we stand right now on Doomsday Clock
you're looking at a situation where a
lot of people are just kind of like okay
so like it's a story that exists and I
think that DC's really felt that right I
think that that in the time that
Doomsday Clock has not been had said has
really been been kind of no staged
outright basically delayed you know in
the time that's happened I think that
DC's lost a lot of the momentum they had
and it kind of sucks to see try because
a lot of people were looking at Doomsday
Clock and they were saying okay so
everything that happens after doomsday
clock it's gonna be a result of like
whatever man hadn't did right like
Manhattan changes everything back so you
know where he does this or he does that
or wipes his character out of existence
or maybe it's a you know blackest night
brightest day kind of thing we're like
he just resurrects all these different
characters and then chooses which ones
get to stay you know whatever the case
happened to be a lot of people were
looking at the post Doomsday Clock
landscape which really should have
concluded about a year and a half I
think maybe even two years ago and then
said okay so like you know everything
that comes after this is gonna be really
really awesome and instead they're kind
of looking at Doomsday Clock and then
they look at a lot of things like you're
the villain they look at all these
different stories heroes in crisis which
as much as I enjoyed it wasn't the most
well-received story by by hardcore comic
book fans they look at a lot of these
things that are kind of like so where is
this going like what's the point of this
like like is it really just a series of
successive stories and if it is let us
know but like what it seems right now is
you're building up to a big event but I
thought this big event was supposed to
come off the coattails of Doomsday Clock
now is it gonna come off the coattails
and what's going on with Scott Snyder's
Justice League like what's going on here
and so I think that in the confusion and
with a lot of stuff kind of up in the
air people not really sure where DC is
because maybe DC's not sure where DC's
going altum Utley I think a lot of the
momentum they had coming out of coming
out of DC universe rebirth number one it
has kind of been lost and of course that
opened the door for marvelous swoop in
especially because they hired CB
Cebulski as editor and chief who's
basically a fan and in one fell swoop
they totally took over that momentum and
now Marvel's absolutely rushing it over
on their side of things but with regards
to doomsday clock itself you know a lot
of these theories that are going on
different
things like that there are a few
prevailing theories that are really
really interesting here right there's
there's a few theories here that that
are that are really really solved and
one of these theories is is that but
essentially the specter will intervene
rather the spectre will intervene at the
end of Doomsday Clock number 12 and this
is actually a really really cool theory
and I really dig this because one of the
things that that Geoff Johns really
loves in DC Comics is the old stuff
right Jeff Johnson loves the old stuff
he loves he loves like the really old
stories with the old characters you know
with like Barry Allen back in the day
some reason why he brought Barry Allen
and or at least you know had Barry Allen
brought in as the new flash when new 52
launched instead of keeping Wally West
is because Geoff Johns loves Barry Allen
you know and and well he isn't the
original flash I would say that for a
lot of people out there he is right I
mean you look at Jay dirt and you say
yes you see original flash but in
reality he was more of a flash prototype
can this character work and then when
you go into DC showcase number four you
get Barry Allen who is a flash like 30
years you know 30 30 some odd years I
want to say like 31 years or so when
prices on a minotaurs happen and so you
got a lot of these really really cool
stories you know with us with his
character but you know depending on what
era you're coming from maybe you are
super old hat you really prefer the old
school old school characters but the
spectre is about as old school as it
gets right I mean this guy has been
around one of the one of the very first
comic book characters to be introduced
by a bi-national halide before it even
became DC Comics when it merged with
all-american and so he's super super
old-school but one of the things that
we've seen with dr. Manhattan if we've
seen him face off against Magic right
we've seen him face off against various
superpowers we saw that when he fought
that Justice League right now in terms
of just super-powered beings they didn't
really matter much to him and with
regards to magic dr. Manhattan was like
you all you're doing all you're doing is
just using what's left of the universe
she does manipulating fabrice of the
universe but like you're not doing
anything that I cannot do and you
haven't done anything that I cannot
overcome right so he was just like done
like he just took out although all the
magic wielders and all the superheroes
at the same time the question becomes
how would dr. Manhattan fare against
like divine power right the power of God
basically because that's what the
spectre is the spectre is a living
embodiment of God's judgment or God's
wrath whatever version you want to go
with and so he is a supremely powerful
channeling the power of God well he
hasn't necessarily got himself in so far
as he cannot do everything the presents
can he's still extremely capable the
ability to time travel different things
like that and so seeing someone at the
specter intervene would be intriguing
the fun thing about this though it's the
specter is not the end all be all right
we've seen the specter defeated by like
Necron you know the the walking talking
embodiment or at least one of the
aspects of death as it pertains to the
Green Lantern mythos so like we've seen
the spectre defeated and overcome in in
various iterations the question is if
you're talking about somebody like dr.
Manhattan who can manipulate matter on
the atomic level then everything is
composed of matter right like if it
exists it's composed of matter divine or
otherwise and so if the spectre has a
form then the specters made of matter
meaning the specter could be controlled
by dr. Manhattan or perhaps even just
dis corporative right you know he shows
up and the SPECT and then dr. Manhattan
just like what are you and the spectre
is like on the embodiment of God's
judgment and I judge you you know as
being a bad guy basically and so now you
have to go away and document happens
like no I'm good and just waves his hand
like there goes a Spectre just kind of
disappears and then that's basically it
you know I have no idea I think that
would be hilarious I think that'd be so
funny they did that if the spectres just
like you have to go and document hands
like nah man I'm watching golden Bros
I'm good just like claps his hand and
the spectre just disappears and like
this this scream you know basically but
there's another theory here this says
that like dr. Manhattan would revert
back to Jon Osterman right this idea
that that man had would get into this
universe and and you know by virtue of
talking to Superman what essentially
regain his humanity right because one of
the big things about Manhattan there was
really a part of Alan Moore's Watchmen
on and really even kind of a mainstay
here in Doomsday Clock because Geoff
Johns
what's one to stay true to the original
narrative and nature of the cure tour
some of the Watchmen stories is that
once Osterman transcended and became dr.
Manhattan he didn't care but he didn't
really care about people for him who was
they were they were ants going about
some insignificant life that wasn't
really relevant to him and so as a
result of that that's why he ended up
leaving he was like okay whatever you
know like like literally I can do pretty
much anything I want to you know I can I
can do all kinds of crazy stuff I
perceive time in a way that would drive
all of you insane if you saw it the same
way that I do
ah and you guys are squabbling over
and you guys are pointing nukes at each
other because you guys are worried about
you know capitalism versus communism
like I've got better things to do it's
been real and it's been good but it
ain't been real good peace you know and
he would basically you know he basically
bailed out but but he was disconnected
from his humanity he didn't care about
people but wouldn't it be intriguing and
wouldn't it be a great kind of Heil kind
of a homage to Superman if Superman by
virtue of talking to dr. Manhattan even
if he doesn't necessarily walk away from
his godly powers assuming that even
could but instead somebody just kind of
takes on the mantle of Osterman almost
kind of becomes this Martian Manhunter s
character right well there's the human
side and then the the ultra-powerful
side you know or with Superman right
there's the Clark Kent and Superman
dichotomy assuming that you know the
assuming that that happened it would
actually be an amazing concept the issue
that you have with this and this is one
of the struggles you're gonna have with
somebody like Manhattan
who's continually existing in the DC
Universe is that you're gonna have the
Franklin Richards effect right Franklin
ragers is this ultra powerful character
in comics and in Marvel Comics of the
question is will this major events
popping off and Franklin Richards can do
anything then why doesn't Franklin
Richards stop it and that's the question
people are gonna have when it comes to
Manhattan is if Manhattan continues to
exist in the DC Universe then say like
some major crisis event shows up right
you know some some huge thing happens
Perpetua or something like that people
are gonna say why doesn't dr. Manhattan
just stop her right if he can control
all forms of matter if he transcends the
multiverse and he's just this ultra
powerful being who was powerful enough
to destroy the white Lantern's then like
why doesn't he just stop Perpetua
assuming that he even could right now if
he couldn't it be interesting because we
don't really know how perpetual ranks in
power to dr. Manhattan because we have a
really seen dr. Manhattan extend the
full limits of what he's capable of
right so we don't know the absolute
limits of his power right we haven't
seen him turn the entire city of Gotham
into like sock puppets right we haven't
seen him that'd be hilarious we haven't
seen him turn you know the whole of
Metropolis into like teddy bears right
II know that to turn the Sun into a
teddy bear that'd be kind of cool but
kind of creepy at the same time you know
like a giant teddy bear in the sky like
you guys ruin a good job
that'd be kind of wild and kind of crazy
but but on the less we haven't seen that
kind of Display of power yet and so the
question becomes you know if you're
talking about something like that
how does it compare to that sort of
character but again I kind of want to
reiterate here that's what you would run
into you as people would ask a question
where's dr. Manhattan and why hasn't he
stopped it yet plus for future riders it
makes it too easy to end a story but
what you don't want to do
it's feed future writers in such a way
to where they can essentially kind of
take the easy way out
it's what Brian Michael Bendis was well
known for doing and in Marvel Comics
over the years that's one of the things
that we don't really want to see happen
and in DC I mean granted it wasn't a
whole lot that he did but like it was
things like he created Matthew Malloy
and didn't know how to write himself out
of it right so what he did is he
basically had the x-men travel back in
time and prevent Matthew Malloy from
being born in order to keep his
character from existing just different
things like that you know it was it was
kind of wildly kind of crazy and so yeah
because of that I want to get into the
final theory here I want to get to the
final theory which I think is the most
interesting one and it was actually one
that a fan sent to me right so those are
guys who were who were unfamiliar on my
Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson I live
stream every Monday Wednesday and Friday
on Instagram and talked to you guys
right like I'll literally add you guys
to the to the stream and then like we'll
go live together and just talk about
things um and and and one of the things
that that I did I think I grabbed a kid
named Nigel I think was his name
I came over his name off top my head but
he had this theory about why it is a dr.
Manhattan could not see past Superman
and I said okay so what's this theory
that you have and he said it's because
basically the Speed Force opens up and
like all the speedsters come out and my
thought was okay but like how does that
have anything to do with anything and he
made a remain a really good point in
saying that in the flash TV show right
now
which may explain why it is a series was
delayed for so long but in the flash TV
show right now what they basically said
is inside the Speed Force or tachyons
and tachyons of course are you know
essentially disrupt the perception of
dr. Manhattan he can't see past them
right it's like a giant fog a giant kind
of blanket sitting over his face and so
what it would mean is that if the the
philosophy of the flash TV show which is
to say the introduction of tachyons as
part of the Speed Force in the flash TV
show was rolled over into Doomsday Clock
or if it was always going to be in the
Doomsday Clock and they were just
waiting for it to be to be done in the
TV show first he would make perfect
sense because what it would mean is that
in this moment where Superman goes to
face off against dr. Manhattan this
suddenly a rift in the Speed Force opens
and all the speedsters that we haven't
seen come pouring out right so here
comes max mercury here comes Jay Garrick
here comes all these different
speedsters that we've been waiting to
see return who basic
hop back up again and they all faced off
against dr. Manhattan alongside Superman
possibly even give him the power of the
flash you know allow him to basically
tap into the Speed Force itself and they
all end up defeating dr. Manhattan it
would be an amazing idea and it'd be an
amazing concept and there's precedents
for this right there's precedents for
the idea of of comic books postponing a
story and then waiting for a TV show to
do it right I eat the deficit uberman
the idea was that when Superman died in
in the early 1990s that was not
originally going to happen what was
originally going to happen if Superman
was going to marry Lois Lane in the
comic books but this TV show The
Adventures of Lois and Clark they were
the ones who were supposed to do it
first right Warner Brothers was like no
no no the TV show was gonna do it first
then you guys can do in the comic since
they had to postpone the marriage in the
comics which they did after Superman
died then the two of them got married
and so as a results that there's
precedents for the swear there's
precedents for a TV show introducing a
consular release you know a concept
possibly being introduced in the comics
but being postponed in the comics so it
can be introduced in a TV show and then
be reflected in the comics ah there's
precedents for that right so this works
this would actually actually be a really
really really amazing thing I would love
it if that were the case if all the
various speedsters made their return I
would absolutely love that but what I
want to do here you know kind of getting
to the second half of our show you know
what I want to do here is I just feel
great
[Music]
you